โมเดลการเขียนโปรแกรมเป็นข้อกำหนดพื้นฐานที่นิยามว่า
ซอฟต์แวร์ถูกจัดโครงสร้างอย่างไร
และทำงานอย่างไร โมเดลเหล่านี้ให้กรอบการทำงาน
ให้นักพัฒนาสามารถแสดงอัลกอริทึม
และจัดระเบียบโค้ด โดยมักซ่อนรายละเอียดระดับล่าง
ของฮาร์ดแวร์หรือสภาพแวดล้อมการรัน
โมเดลต่างๆ เหมาะกับปัญหาต่างประเภท
และฮาร์ดแวร์ต่างกัน ซึ่งให้ระดับ
การ abstract และการควบคุมที่แตกต่างกัน
ในบทนี้
เราจะทบทวนโมเดลการเขียนโปรแกรมทั้งควอนตัมและคลาสสิก
และดูว่าเราสามารถรวมกันเพื่อรัน algorithm
อย่างไร
เริ่มด้วยโมเดลการเขียนโปรแกรม
สำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม โมเดลการเขียนโปรแกรมพื้นฐานอย่างหนึ่ง
ที่นักพัฒนาควอนตัมแทบทุกคนรู้จัก
คือ quantum circuit เราจะไม่ลงรายละเอียด
เรื่อง quantum circuit
ในที่นี้ เพราะมีแหล่งข้อมูลดีๆ อยู่แล้วมากมาย
รวมถึงบรรยายของ Joan Waters
จะกล่าวแค่ว่า circuit ประกอบด้วย
เส้นที่เรียกว่า wire ซึ่งแทน qubit
รวมถึง gate ที่แทนการดำเนินการบนสถานะควอนตัม
และชุดการวัดผล
แนวคิดโมเดลการเขียนโปรแกรมที่สำคัญอีกอย่าง
สำหรับ
primitive เหล่านี้แทนงานที่ได้รับความนิยมมากที่สุด
ที่ผู้ใช้ต้องการทำกับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ตอนนี้มี primitive อยู่สองตัว
คือ Sampler และ Estimator โดย Sampler ให้ความสามารถ
ในการ sample สถานะที่ quantum circuit เตรียมไว้
และ Estimator ให้ประมาณค่า expectation value ของ
observable สำหรับระบบในสถานะที่ quantum
circuit เตรียมไว้ แนวคิดสุดท้าย
ที่จะพูดถึงในส่วนนี้
คือ transpilation โดย transpilation
คือกระบวนการแปลง circuit ที่ป้อนเข้ามา
ให้ตรงกับ topology ของอุปกรณ์ควอนตัมที่เจาะจง
เพื่อรัน
บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมที่มี noise
คล้ายกับ compiler คลาสสิก
routine ของ transpiler จะค่อยๆ ปรับ
โครงสร้างของ circuit โดยใช้ชุด pass
ทีนี้มาพูดถึงโมเดลการเขียนโปรแกรมคลาสสิก
มีโมเดลการเขียนโปรแกรมหลายแบบ
สำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
แต่ในบทนี้จะเน้นสองแบบ
ที่ได้รับความนิยมมากที่สุดคือ parallel programming
และ task workflow การใช้สองโมเดลนี้
ร่วมกับโมเดลการเขียนโปรแกรมควอนตัม
ทำให้สามารถแสดง hybrid
quantum-classical workflow ที่ซับซ้อนแค่ไหนก็ได้
โมเดล parallel programming
แบ่งโปรแกรมออกเป็นปัญหาย่อยที่รันได้
พร้อมกัน มีสองแนวทางหลักของ parallel programming
คือ shared memory parallelism และ distributed memory parallelism
สำหรับที่นี่ เรามุ่งไปที่ distributed memory model
distributed memory model
ใช้ process อิสระบน core แยกกัน
หรือ node แยกกัน โดยแต่ละ process มี memory ของตัวเอง
และการสื่อสารผ่าน message passing มี
แนวคิดบางอย่างที่ควรรู้
อย่างแรกคือ process
ซึ่งเป็น instance อิสระของโปรแกรม
ที่รันบน core แยกต่างหาก
จากนั้นคือ rank ซึ่งเป็น identifier เฉพาะของ process
และแนวคิด single program
multiple data หรือ SPMD abstraction model
ซึ่งเป็น abstraction model
สำหรับการคำนวณ ที่โปรแกรม instance เดียว
ถูกกระจายไปยัง node หลายตัว
ซอร์สโค้ดจึงเหมือนกัน
แต่ข้อมูลบน node เหล่านั้นต่างกัน
การรันโมเดล parallel programming
เกิดขึ้นในลักษณะนี้
โปรแกรมเดียวถูกส่งไปยัง node หลายตัว
และเริ่ม process แบบ parallel หลายตัว
การควบคุม flow ของโปรแกรมถูกกำหนดโดย rank
หรือ identifier ของ process นั้น
และการสื่อสารเกิดขึ้น
ผ่าน message passing
โมเดล task workflow
abstract การคำนวณเป็น graph หรือ DAG
โดยแต่ละ node ใน graph คืองานเฉพาะ
หรือ job และ edge คือ dependency ของข้อมูล
และลำดับ ตัวอย่างหาได้จากเอกสารของเรา
ที่จริง sequence ที่พูดถึงเสมอในควอนตัม
computing อย่าง mapping, optimisation
execution และ post-processing
ก็คือ task workflow โมเดลหนึ่ง
ที่งานทุกอย่างรันทีละขั้น
ต่อเนื่องกันใน pipeline
แต่ด้วย task workflow
เราไม่ถูกจำกัดให้รันตามลำดับ
และสามารถรัน task แบบ parallel ได้
แต่ละ task หรือ workflow สามารถเป็น parallel job ขนาดใหญ่ได้
ในตัวเอง ดังนั้นจึงผสมผสาน
โมเดลเหล่านี้เพื่อแสดง algorithm
ที่ซับซ้อนแค่ไหนก็ได้
ลองนำแนวคิดที่เรียนมาประยุกต์ใช้กับโค้ดกัน
ก่อนอื่นจะลองรัน hello world ง่ายๆ
โดยใช้ paradigm ของ parallel programming
เราจะใช้ Open MPI
ซึ่งเป็น implementation ของ MPI protocol
ซึ่งเป็นมาตรฐานสำหรับ message passing
ใน parallel programming
ก่อนอื่นต้องมีโปรแกรมของเรา
ที่นี่เราใช้ mpi4py
ซึ่งเป็น Python binding
สำหรับ MPI และจะเห็นว่าเราใช้ rank เพื่อตัดสิน
control flow ของโปรแกรม
ทีนี้มาดู submission script กัน
จะเห็นว่าเราจะใช้สอง node
หนึ่ง task ต่อ node ใน normal partition
และรันโปรแกรม รอสักครู่
แล้วดูผลลัพธ์ของ job
จะเห็นว่ามี log output ของโปรแกรมเรา
ใช้สอง node และสอง process
ซึ่งระบุด้วย rank
อย่างที่เห็นเป็น output
rank 0 และ rank 1 ถูกใช้ตัดสิน
control flow ของโปรแกรม
จะเห็นว่า process rank 0 ส่ง
payload ไปยัง process rank 1
และ process rank 1 รับมัน
payload นั้น มาพูดถึง task workflow กัน
มีเครื่องมือที่เรียกว่า workload
management system ซึ่งออกแบบมาโดยเฉพาะ
สำหรับรัน workflow ที่ซับซ้อน
แต่เพื่อไม่ให้ยุ่งยากเกินไป เราจะใช้ฟีเจอร์ built-in
dependency ใน Slurm
เพื่อสร้าง computational graph
ก่อนอื่นต้องมี task ของ workflow
ที่พร้อมแล้ว นี่คือโค้ดเดิม
ข้อดีของการแบ่ง task เหล่านี้
เป็น mapping, optimisation, execution
และ post-processing เป็นขั้นตอนแยกกัน
คือเราสามารถกำหนด resource requirement เฉพาะ
สำหรับแต่ละ task เช่น mapping, optimisation
และ post-processing ไม่จำเป็นต้องใช้
quantum resource
ดังนั้นรันบน classical partition ได้เลย
แต่ task execution จะต้องการ
quantum resource จึงรันบน quantum
partition
ทีนี้มาใช้ฟีเจอร์ dependency เพื่อเชื่อม task
เข้าเป็น workflow กัน
จะเห็นว่ายังรันอยู่
sbatch command พร้อม flag --parsable
ซึ่งจะคืนค่า job ID
จากนั้นส่ง job ID นั้น
เป็น dependency ให้กับ task อื่นๆ
สำหรับ job ต่างๆ จะเห็นว่ากำลังรัน
job ใน workflow พร้อม dependency
เมื่อ workflow ทั้งหมดเสร็จแล้ว ก็ดูผลลัพธ์ได้
จะเห็นว่าได้ค่า expectation value กลับมา
และยังดูผลลัพธ์ทั้งหมดของ
แต่ละขั้นตอนได้ด้วย
ซึ่งก็อยู่ตรงนี้
เท่านี้สำหรับส่วน programming model
บทถัดไปจะพูดถึง algorithm ขั้นสูง
ต่างๆ